Thing,
the other thing about marriage,
this is really worth knowing too,
is that I learned this in part from
reading youngest,
like what do you do when you get
married?
That's easy.
You take someone who's just as useless
and horrible as you are,
and then you shackle yourself to them
and then you say,
we're not running away no matter what
happens.
Yeah.
Well that's perfect because then you
don't get to run away and the thing is
is like if you can run away,
you can't tell each other the truth
because if you tell someone the truth
about you and they don't run away,
they weren't listening and so if you
don't have someone around that can't run
away,
then you can't tell them the truth,
and so that's part of the purpose of the
marriage.
It's like,
okay,
I'll bet on you.
You bet on me.
It's a losing bet.
We both know that,
but given our current circumstances,
we're unlikely to find anyone better.
For sure.
Two things that come off of that.
One is you know,
people are waiting around to find Mr and
Mrs.
Right?
It's like,
here's something to think about,
man,
to put yourself on your feet,
right?
If you went to a party and you found Mr
Wright and he looked at you and didn't
run away screaming,
that would indicate that he wasn't Mr
Wright at all.
Right?
It's like the old Nietzschean joke.
If someone loves you,
that should immediately disenchanted
with them.
Right?
Right.
Or it's the woody Allen joke.
I never belonged to a club that would
take me as a member.
So,
so that's,
uh,
that's an interesting.
That's a very interesting thing to think
about.
And so you're going to shackle yourself
to someone who's just as far as
imperfect as you are.
And then the issue is you,
you,
you might be in a situation where you
can actually negotiate because you might
think,
well,
there's some things about you that
aren't going so right.
And there's some things about me that
aren't going so right and we're bloody
well stuck with the consequences for the
next 50 years.
So we can,
we can either straighten this out or we
can suffer through it for the next five
decades.
And you know,
people are of the sort that without that
degree of seriousness,
those problems will not be solved.
You'll leave things unnamed because
there's always an out.
It's like.
And it's the same thing when you're
living together with someone.
You know that people who live together
before they're married are more likely
to get divorced,
not less likely.
And the reason for that is,
what exactly are you saying to one
another when you live with each other?
Just think about it.
Well,
for now you're better than anything else
I can trick,
but I'd like to reserve the right to
trade you in conveniently.
If someone happens to stumble into me,
well how can,
how can ?
Someone
not be insulted to their core by an
offer like that.
Now they're willing to play along with
it because they're going to do the same
thing with you.
That will.
That's exactly it.
It's like,
yeah,
I know you're not going to commit to me.
So that means you don't value me or our
relationship above everything else,
but as long as I get to escape,
if I need to,
then I'm willing to put up with that.
It's like that's a hell of a thing.
I mean,
you might think,
how stupid is it to shackle yourself to
someone?
It's like,
it's stupid,
man.
There's no doubt about that,
but compared to the alternatives,
it's pretty damn good because without
that shackling,
there are things you will never ever
learned because you'll avoid them.
You can always leave and if you can
leave,
then you don't have to tell each other
the truth.
It's as simple as that because you can
just leave and then you don't have
anyone.
You can tell the truth too.